METE ATAMEL: Let's
see how to run Windows
Container on Compute Engine.
First, we need a Windows VM.
In Google Cloud Console, go
to the Compute Engine Section
and create an instance.
Make sure Windows
Server for Containers
is selected for the boot disk.
Create a Windows password
and use that password to RDP
into the instance.
Now let's pull another server
image that includes PowerShell
and run it as a container.
This will take us
inside the container.
Now create a Hello
World PowerShell script
and exit the container.
Get the container ID
and create a new image
from the modified container.
Finally, create and
run a container based
on the image we just created.
There you go.
You're running a Windows
container on Google Cloud.